we've been waiting on Amazon to announce
several big projects and MGM who are
obviously owned by Amazon there might be
the most ridiculous reason why we've
been waiting and why we still might have
to wait a few more
months you're not going to believe this
one welcome to Sidra your Sci-Fi TV and
movie
[Music]
channel
so this is very much in the rumor
category I have to say and stress that
very much the sourcer
said nobody seems to know exactly what
Amazon are doing but this is the rumor
that's going around the
industry basically they haven't
restarted several projects that they had
begun before the strike
so before the writer strikes before the
actors went on strike there were several
projects that were in production and
they've not restarted them now according
to the source that I've been speaking to
that worked in the agent side of things
people have started to notice because
there's people that are contracted to
those projects that aren't coming back
to work so um there's been rumors
battering around the reason why though
is ridiculous and apparently Amazon are
so embarrassed about this they're not
admitting it
publicly but basically this comes down
to Studio space now Amazon do own a
couple of studios and they own a couple
at Culver City where their headquarters
are and they have been through the
Hackman group acquiring several
more but the Hackman group are building
a lot of these and they're not going to
be apparently up and running until next
summer now Amazon were renting loads of
Studio space but the studio space is
horrendously expensive I mean it's it's
hundreds of thousands of pounds you know
it's it's really expensive you know and
you got if you've got several of them
into millions and millions of pounds so
during the strikes they let a lot of
Studio space go they put sets into
storage and apparently they basically
were saving money
the Assumption being that as soon as the
strikes ended they would go back in and
they would just write New Deals the
problem is apparently a lot of that
studio space is no longer available
while it was left empty and Amazon
didn't actually actually have anything
contracted to say that as soon as the
strikes were done they would go back in
other companies and other production
firms have have taken lease on these
places so apparently Amazon can't find
any appropriate Studio space for some of
the projects that it has already up and
running never mind New Studio Projects
now the Hackman group are providing and
going to be providing significant Studio
space but as I said a lot of it's not
going to be available till next summer
so Amazon are all of a sudden in a bit
of a pickle they don't have enough
Studio space for the stuff they already
had lined up never mind anything new so
they can't announce Stargate RoboCop
anything else you know Legally Blond
three because they don't know when
they're going to be able to start
filming it because the
morons okay that's unfortunate let's not
use the word let's say
intellectually challenged managers over
Amazon didn't do the basic job of
getting Studio
space now okay I know Amazon have got a
long-term plan and that
they are trying to get as much Studio
space of their own as possible rented
off a Hackman group but they're big
investors in the Hackman groups they're
basically renting off themselves but I
know that's the long-term plan it seems
to me and something I actually spoke to
you guys about months ago that Amazon
did see the strikes as an opportunity a
massive reset for one they could
actually stop and have a look at all the
projects they were thinking about doing
they give them Unity to reorganize some
of the management structure and they
hired made two or three hirings big
hirings like and they got a new guy in
actually in charge of production of
feature films well done you've only been
the job a couple of months and you've
literally left them no um Studio pce
allegedly but also they did see this as
a big opportunity to move away from
having to deal with so many partners all
the time you know uh the boys is made in
partnership with Sony Pictures and to be
honest the list goes on and on and on um
Amazon saw this pause during the strikes
as the opportunity to get their own
Studio space lined up and then start
producing things themselves I have
actually heard the rumor as well
potentially
that another reason why they're pausing
things is so they can get into their own
Studio space and maybe cut ties with
some of those partners that they didn't
necessarily want to be involved in the
first place I don't see how that's going
to work though when it's a production of
already uper up and running sort of
thing because contracts have been agreed
but that was what I was told I'm not not
quite sure how that would
work could this actually be true it's
one of those things that sounds so
ridiculous and so stupid it could be
true it would explain a lot it would
explain why we're still getting delays
it would explain why they seem not to
have restarted lots of projects that
they could have done the writers have
been off strike for two or 3 months now
the writers could be back in but they're
not apparently now this doesn't seem to
be all their projects it seems to be
some but a but a significant
number one explanation for that is this
rumor that there just isn't the studio
space for it now there is a massive
shortage of sh Studio space um the
Hackman group are building all over the
place Pinewood Studio are building all
over the place um there's a lot of um
one of the reasons why there's a big
shortfall currently Studio space is
though actually because the Hackman
group and others are actually
redeveloping large studio spaces
actually the Stargate outside of
Vancouver the studio the Stargate was um
uh filmed originally is actually going
through a massive Redevelopment at the
moment I think the Hackman group is
spending like six billion quid or
something 60 million 6 billion something
like that there's a six in it a lot of
money um on massively redeveloping in
the site so obviously while you're
redeveloping somewhere that studio isn't
in use um and that's happening all over
there's a another big big project in
irand at the moment going on and I think
Hackman group are involved in that as
well actually if you don't know the
Hackman group are the single largest
private owner Studio space in the world
didn't exist like 15 years ago but now
they're the biggest um so yeah there's
lots of projects going on thanks to
streaming and stuff so we've got a lot
of content being produced and also so a
lot of Studios being
redeveloped modernizing them basically
um one of the things they're doing a lot
in the studio space is creating um
basically massive LED screens that the
actors then work in front of and instead
they call it b a virtual background so
instead of having green screens they can
have this just it's basically a massive
freaking Telly but I mean it's a size of
an enormous War um and it's making a lot
of digital um movies and things much
cheaper much quicker because you can
just keep changing the background youd
have to build massive sets and things um
the newest Eddie Murphy the Christmas
film is the first one that MGM uh sorry
Amazon have built because they've
actually got the world's largest virtual
studio um at cver city and um I think it
comes out at Christmas so wa for that
see if you can tell when you watch it um
so yeah is it
possible
hey sometimes truth is Stranger Than
Fiction you can't argue with that
sometimes it's just weird I can't quite
get my head around it but if it's true
it's really
stupid but the sort of thing that does
happen
so like I said makes might explain a few
things but guys get into the comments
and tell me what you think I apologize
doing these Quick videos I'm on my
holidays at the moment and I've
literally just had this email so I
thought I'd do something about it
straight away but um it's just it's just
it's thrown me a little bit I I just I
don't quite know what to think about it
so why don't you get into the comments
and tell me what I should think about it
because you know your opinions really
are all that
matter if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit the Bell
notification it really helps us out do
all those buttony things you can also go
to patreon.com citre where most of our
new videos do Premiere first and you can
go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where I'll be doing an article about
this very story and this very
possibility tomorrow if I get time
fascinating as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time